[Music]
a mountain lion is on the loose right
now in our valley wildlife officials
don't know where it is the mountain lion
was last seen though near harmon and
jones and spring valley if you live in
that area keep an eye out keep an eye on
your pets avoid walking alone and that's
where we find 8 news now victoria sahoo
who has more victoria
yeah denise earlier this afternoon there
was several metro police cars and
wardens here trying to spine that
mountain lion but they lost sight of him
and then that's why they had to leave
that's still on the loose right now
a monday afternoon mountain lion
sighting caused two schools to go on a
soft lockdown clark county school police
say the mountain lion described as 70 to
80 pounds was first spotted in a
backyard by kenny gwynn middle school
while the students were out for recess
we spoke with crystal jensen who first
spotted the mountain lion sleeping under
a tree in her backyard by the school
that's a scary part that it's still on
the loose to be honest because you don't
know where it could have went she says
officers did their best to contain the
mountain lion in her backyard as they
worked on tranquilizing it but then it
ran away perimeters were set all the way
to dondero elementary school as the
animal moved towards a neighborhood
nearby back in january a mountain lion
was spotted and then euthanized near el
capitan on spring mountain
police say you should try to stay in
doris tonight and also keep your pets
inside but
keep an eye out on your surroundings
especially the trees up there on top of
it that is where mountain lions usually
like to hang out reporting from spring
valley tonight victoria saha live local
now